oppo finding sopo find x5 propos find
x52 smartphones qui sont la garde sur la
paf posé sur la table c'est aujourd'hui
une vidéo qui a réalisé en partenariat
des copeaux alors attention je vous le
dis soyons clairs aux pommade il ya
quelques temps au monsieur grehan on va
sortir très prochainement dans nos
nouveaux smartphones très haut de gamme
j'ai dit ok c'est cool ça me plaît bien
ça m'intéresse ok jusque là tout va bien
et ils m'ont dit on aimerait bien faire
un partenariat avec toi je dis ok ok
pourquoi pas on y va allez c'est parti
alors sachez que tout ce qui est dit ici
parce que je sais que souvent dues à vis
des horizons partenariat gnagna tu t'es
fait acheter non soyons clairs non j'ai
des choses à dire j'ai déjà dit aux pour
qu'on s'est vus il ya pas longtemps
j'aime beaucoup ses smartphones il ya
des trucs que j'aime un petit peu moins
j'ai tout vous expliquer alors hop au
travail dans vos slips et vous vous
allez voir on aura d introduire des
produits qu'on a deux qui sont vachement
intéressant et on y va maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on y va on restitue un petit peu
l'histoire on a deux produits très
proche le premier ceo peau fine x5 pro
qui dit pro des plus hauts de gamme on
s'en doutera 1299 avec 99 et vous avez
en face au pauvre finding 5 1 999 euros
alors vous avez des différences notables
bien évidemment que ce soit sur la
performance la batterie son dragon 8
génois ndu ziga drame snapdragon 888 8
gigas de ram 5 millions t1 hors batterie
recharge rapide filière 80 watts sans
fil 53 4800 millions t1 en batterie
recharge filaire 80 watts recharge son
fils 33 qui est déjà très très bien on
va avoir à peu près la même chose en
photo sauf que ici vous avez une
stylisation sur cinq axes comme on
aurait un peu dans l'idée sur en boîtier
vous savez du 5 axes une superstar mais
pour un mec comme moi qu'un tremblement
essentiel croyez moi c'est vachement
cool la voa brutalisation optique ce qui
est déjà très très très bien qu est ce
que vous avez comme différent cela vous
en avez forcément au niveau de la
diagonale de l'écran que j'ai jamais
appris par coeur cette d'un godet quand
ici là on a quoi on a un système de 7
pouces wqs du plus et puis là on est sur
du style ce qu'ont à 6 55 pouces full hd
+ avaya une différence bien évidemment
au niveau des diago mais également au
niveau des techno sur le pro ans va être
sûr du ltp au amoled dans les cellules t
ltps amoled taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz de tous les côtés et sur le
prendre à un ip 68 là on a un ip 54
c'est bizarre mais bon il pèse 54 et
puis voilà un peu les grosses
différences et ce qui est venu fer
oppose ce qui fâche moins intéressant si
vous voulez c'est l'idée de se dire on
veut être dans l'esprit photographique
on veut venir apporter vraiment de la
photographier toutes les marques vous
dit ça aujourd'hui j'en ai connaît pas
une qui me disent bien je vais pas faire
ma photo tient si vous un truc un petit
peu mal non je ne connais aucune ils
veulent tous faire de la photo alors
avec plus ou moins de succès il installé
à vous savez aujourd'hui pourquoi est ce
que toutes les marques veulent
absolument faire de la photo et vous
bien la photo de ce voyage pas comme
souvent vos amis chers consommateurs et
bien c'est tout simplement parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un usage majeur on
utilise nos smartphones pour jouer donc
il faut de la performance pour le gaming
donc pour cent au niveau marketing et
puis on fait des photos on n'achète plus
aujourd'hui d'appareils quoi on avec
nous donc on fait de la photo avec nos
smartphones donc toutes les marques vous
dise ah ben tiens on insulte un appareil
alors il y en a certains qui vont faire
de la photographie computationnelle
aussi dire qu'on adule il ya derrière
qui va venir booster tout ça mais qui
s'appuyent un petit peu trop dessus et
des fois ça dénature un peu les photos
il y en a d'autres qui ont des choses
très équilibré et qui sont très très
beau mais là est ce qui me plaît
beaucoup avec le pro le finepix ac il
est un peu à part il est bien mais
j'adhère tout à l'heure avec le finepix
5 prône un résultat qui est très
surprenant honni la photo c'est à dire
que j'ai l'impression d'avoir des
résultats comme je pourrais avoir avec
un boîtier j'ai fait de la photo alors
c'est pas la même chose je vais pas
venir comparer avec le boîtier que le
4ème film est tout de suite voyait ou
avec d'autres appareils ça ça coûte
quatre mille balles à ça coûte 1200
euros c'est pas la même chose néanmoins
on est de vrais belle expérience
photographique on va pas chercher des
choses qui n'existent pas on va pas
venir créer des scènes qui n'existe pas
avec de l'intelligence artificielle
qu'il ira trop loin d'un certain qu'ils
le font ici ce n'est pas le cas mais
pour vous montrer je vais faire quoi je
vais prendre mon ordi vous allez voir
parce que franchement j'en ai c'est
beaucoup de smartphones jantes est
énormément il a plein que j'adore je
trouve intéressant avec des forces et
les faiblesses président c'est une des
premières fois que je vais être assez
bluffé par un smartphone alors attention
c'est pas parfait à plein de choses qui
vont pas et je vais vous le dire mais je
suis assez bluffé pourquoi parce que
j'ai l'impression vraiment d'être dans
l'esprit de la faute au temps des photos
envoyées et pas être dans l'esprit de
dire on va sur flatter le consommateur
on va lui montrer des choses très belles
qui n'existe pas là je fais de la photo
ça me plaît allez on y va comme diraient
les américains au mic gauche ça claque
vraiment ça claque regardez moi cette
photo alors ça fait porter des photos
que j'ai déjà montré lorsque j'étais à
homme il ya quelques temps je trouve que
c'est super beau alors effectivement il
ya de l'iag à rien parce que là vous
avez prennent le soleil en pleine
tronche et on voit bien le bâtiment mais
pour autant je trouve que dans l'esprit
photographique et que ça marche vraiment
très très bien je vous avait déjà montré
plein de photos là qui sont sur la
première vidéo donc je vais passer très
très rapidement pour vous emmener sur
autre chose regardez ne serait ce que la
photo du colisée je la trouve incroyable
on a bien les nuages on voit bien
effectivement que le temps est pas ouf
mais ça va alors il ya un poil de
sursaturation niveau de l'abattoir on
savait qu'ils ont un peu poussée d'un
point de vue gobain samedi un enjeu
patrouilles mais bon ça conviendra
l'ultra grand temps où il fait le taff
aussi vraiment à l'origine anti-free
forme c'est pas la première année que au
pot nous la présente cette lentille qui
va éviter la déformation avec un plus
grand temps que ça marche vraiment très
très très jolie extrêmement efficace et
puis voyons peu miné se rapprocher un
peu alors on va pas trop trop loin
attention va se calmer sur les ou noyés
lorsque je vais beaucoup trop loin tout
de suite c'est vraiment pas ouf c'est
flou dont je dirais qu'on peut venir
nous met un petit peu mais on va y aller
calme et tranquille où les amis parce
qu'évidemment ça fonctionnera pas je
monte quelques petites images c'est
pareil ça fonctionne bien bon qu'ils
lanceront pas trop content on est une
petite différence totalement con un peu
moins de lumière qui est capté par votre
capteur ultra grand-angle mais c'est
assez normal mais on a des choses qui
sont très très sympa que je trouve
vraiment très très jolie une fois de
plus haut niveau la photo a rejoint zulu
un peu trop mais ça ne sert à rien
d'être plein jour là comme ça qu'ultra
grand-angle on arrive on chope le
panthéon à rome c'est juste magnifique
alors bien évidemment on le voir aller
sur les parties du bas là bas il ya une
correction mais malgré une petite
distorsion là est bon on va éviter de
mettre des visages aussi en bas dans les
angles comme ça quand on fait du travail
en temps parce que c'est pas là que ça
va être la meilleure ce que je vous
montrez moi c'est la nuit un nouveau
c'est vraiment très très très beau alors
c'est très très beau ouais sauf l'ultra
grand tante qui la nuit fais pas trop le
taf mais une fois de plus ce sont des
ultra grand-angle ne s'est pas fait pour
faire des photos nous y soyons clairs
c'est pareil on peut venir vous aimez la
nuit on va hésiter j'ai quelques petits
trucs intéressants la fontaine de trevi
la garder comme s'il ya un souci du
détail des ombres des jeux de lumière il
ya de l'ia qui travaillent bien derrière
enfin bref c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment maîtriser une fois de plus
ultra grand temps qu'on va venir éviter
or la caméra de celle ci elle est un peu
en dessous je trouve qu'au niveau de la
gestion d'autres lumières on n'est pas
très très très bon c'est un peu cramé
derrière mais man au niveau de mes
cheveux voilà c'est parce que je vais
venir préféré c'est pas là tout ce
smartphone très clairement la caméra de
cette fille elle m'a regardé à
l'intérieur dans une galerie c'est
magnifique se savoure sort vous avez du
détail de tous les côtés je trouve que
ça marche vraiment bien super un joli
travail là dessus je vous remets à notre
goût de caméras de celle-ci fouet bon là
c'est un peu meilleur mais même là voyez
je me mets dans différentes situations
avec le soleil sur le côté pour le coup
là ça a été beaucoup mieux géré toujours
un peu les hautes lumières sur le côté
mais bon je vais un peu le chercher dans
ses retranchements c'est un peu meilleur
comme ça quand même lorsqu'on veut
photographier de la nourriture fraîche
que ça fonctionne quand même pas mal
regardez la plage aux gens mais dans le
colisée à l'intérieur français hyper
beau je veux c'est vraiment très très
bien regardez le rendu est quand même
hyper classe et c'est super super super
chouette et la lutte sera grand temps il
fonctionne quand même il faut beaucoup
lumière les gens c'est souvent comme ça
les ultra grand-angle si vous mettez de
la lumière vous et nourrissent et ça
marchera bien on va pas se rapprocher
pas autant ça sert à rien d'aller aussi
loin du bout de souffle et comme c'est
super beau on aime bien les détails
devant même sur l'ultra grand temps
qu'on les aide bien là sur le
grand-angle aussi on a bien bref une
très très bonne gestion de la plage
dynamique ça marche très très bien gardé
hyper bojador oui un côté qui est un peu
d'effarement ça les a grandi ça attire
un peu les jambes donc ça c'est bien
pour les monuments ultra-grand-angle
mais je trouve que pour les personnes
c'est un peu moins bien il ya un mode
que j'ai vraiment adoré cette mode xpan
c'est à dire le mode à seul blade très
allongé comme ça c'est très atypique ça
fait super beau cliché alors bon là je
vais me un petit con tre jours on voit
que le côté là il a quand même eu un peu
du mal à venir récupérer ça c'est assez
brute et parce qu'il est vraiment venu
travailler de façade pour nous faire
ressortir justement la façade là c'est
pas ou feint ce vol je trouve incroyable
et on est dans l'idée de la photographie
et ça marche alors vous avez différents
effets sur du noir et blanc et compagnie
mais je me sens vraiment très très très
beau qui est adoré shooter knicks panne
garder ça marche vous rentrez des choses
avec un format qui est magnifique jeu
démontrer cette photo déjà dans ma vidéo
d'avant avec le colisée je trouve que
c'est juste super jolie et regardez là
en photo nue et le panthéon il est
magnifique superbe aux ultra grand-angle
une fois de plus on oublie la photo de
nuit tout ça vraiment juste magnifique
lundi demande intérieure à ça marche
c'est super joli chassé au musée du
vatican super classe hop là on peut se
rapprocher bon on connaît l'histoire
j'ai regardé ça la nuit tombée je trouve
ça vraiment très très très jolie aux
libyens toutes les écritures ici on a
bien tous les détails le ciel est si au
niveau des éclairages ça ne bave pas
passer précise soit vraiment bien fait
l'ultra grand temps de plus on oublie là
dessus mais je me sens vraiment beau
garder ça aussi c'est vachement bien
donc je pourrais passer des heures à
vous montrer des photos on est déjà oula
ça avance dans le temps dont j'allais un
peu tranquille ou mais je trouve qu'il
ya eu un super beau boulot qui a été
fait ici au sur le grand-angle on a des
très très très jolies photos et de
regarder la sueur de la nourriture ça
c'est du jambon espagnol ça donne envie
alors ça c'est effectivement ce que je
voulais vous montrer du côté du finepix
cinq pros finding 5 c'est un petit peu
différent pour voir qu'on a les mêmes
capteurs vous ça marche quand même bien
façon on a toujours de très jolies
photos noms les moins dans les baies de
la photographie on n'est plus dans la
photographie smartphone un peu plus ton
âme mais quand je dis standard les
canons du très haut de gamme et ça
marche très très bien regarder landais
place real à barcelone super beau nate
est d'aider des lendemains regardez là
c'est pareil on a bien le soleil là on
voit la façade ça marche bien c'est joli
c'est efficace et très très joli alors
elle a eu 30 ans le voyez hop ça
fonctionne je mange des photos un peu
pêle mêle pour mou voiliers mais je
trouve que ça marche bien c'est aussi un
très très beau smartphone parce que l'on
va se dire ok y'a le procès est pas
promis les quinze mille euros c'est
aussi un très très beau photophone très
jolie smartphone est très puissant très
performant alors après ce cas est un peu
surprenant de se dire petit aparté là
sur la partie photo vidéo ça peut être
bizarre de se dire je vais poser mille
euros et je n'ai pas avoir le dernier
processeur si je pense hélas ou au poète
était un petit peu fort au niveau du
tarif ce smartphone là je l'aurais
trouvé intéressant mais un peu moins
cher parce que même si les puissants et
même si le standard 888 marche très très
bien a quasiment 1000 euros la
concurrence peut être un petit peu
complexe ça c'est un truc à boire à
déjouer monde 2000 ça marche quand même
aussi plutôt bien là la gestion des
lumières avec le spes de patience
qu'être pas que c'est parce qu'être parc
la toussaint pas mal alors que là ça va
baver un petit peu sur les lumières là
c'est un peu moins parfaits également de
la nourriture fait le taf si vous donnez
fin avec ces histoires de jambon la
jamon jamon iberico c'est pas mal quand
même à regarder la photo nuit c'est pas
parfait aussi au niveau des lumières
mais sinon dans l'ensemble c'est quand
même très très très très bien on a bien
dû dire et de tous les côtés on voit
bien la cime des arbres on a bien tout
tout est bien bien géré ça c'est
efficace même sur l'ultra grand temps
que ce pas mauvais or après on va vite
idiot mais quand on n'a pas beaucoup de
lumière gardel s'intégrer l'hyper mignon
ça une fois de plus c'est la nourriture
ainsi une fondue chinoise très très bon
voyez très cool et vous pouvez même bien
pousser jusqu'au bout de la nuit comme
ça soit bien vous amuser sortir en club
mais tant qu'à un poil mieux on peut le
faire donc bon voilà glow rendu est cool
je passe un petit peu de temps vous
montrer cette partie photo vidéo parce
que c'est vraiment l'essence de ses
smartphones et notamment sur le modèle
professionnel qui est quand même au
dessus en vidéo aussi je trouve vraiment
bien et il fait très bien le taf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant il ya un truc qui moi me
plaît un petit peu moins sur ce
smartphone le finepix cinq pros cclat
ici j'ai effectivement une stabilisation
optique sur cinq axes et ça c'est cool
regardez moi j'ai les mains qui
tremblent je vous dis une fois plusieurs
tremblement essentiel donc j'ai les
mains qui bouge voilà c'est comme ça
c'est ma particularité mais si
rapidement relou donc là effectivement
ma main tremble et ça ne bouge pas donc
ça c'est bien mais le problème c'est que
sur le zoom optique x 2 eh bien ils
n'ont absolument pas me stabilisation
optique ce qui fait que là tout de suite
on a regardé voyez ça ça pardonne pas
alors moi je suis un vrai crash test
pour les marques donc là on le voit ça
tremble c'est pas ouf et alors ça c'est
le foie de après si je me rapproche et
que je monte à léo va se mettre sur un x
5 là par contre il ya une stade donc là
c'est le logiciel qui vient récupérer et
là ça bouge pas donc là ça corrige donc
là le smartphone qui tremble mais là
l'électronique vient récupérer vient
compenser donc ça c'est bien mais j'ai
du mal à comprendre si vous voulez que
sur un smartphone quasiment 1300 euros
1000 299,99 et bien vous n'ayez pas un
zoom optique x 2 j'en ai parlé aux
équipes de haut qui m'ont dit parce
qu'en fait vous savez quand on construit
des smartphones on va d'abord mettre les
fonctionnalités que les gens utilisent
le plus donc à plus gros focus qui fait
son grand temps guen évidemment et ça
c'est génial également sur l' ultra
grand-angle avec la lentille free forme
et ça marche vachement bien et un petit
peu moins sur le téléobjectif et c'est
toi qui me fait un poil râler parce que
bon moi quand je le 1300 mal je veux
quand même ce qu'elle lui alors ici j'ai
un truc qui est vraiment top j'adore ce
smartphone et je vous dis ne faites plus
super beau boulot très bel écran très
bien calibrée beaucoup de performances
l'audio marche bien on a vraiment une
optimisation niveau de la photo et de la
vidéo avec cette puce mari seal iconique
donc superbe expérience si vous êtes
créateur si vous êtes blogueur si vous
voulez un bel appareil photo si vous
voulez des souvenirs si vous voulez
jouer à des jeux vous avez un super
smartphone très jolie smartphone le
finepix 5 propos y aller les yeux fermés
le fat duck 5 je trouve aussi très
intéressant il marche bien photo vidéo
il sera très efficace un peu en dessous
du fonds indique 5 promet ça me paraît
assez normal néanmoins et d'un super
vendu le petit bémol que je prends à lui
apporter lui alors effectivement il ya
la même question au niveau de la
stabilisation voyez sur le feu d'optique
ça veut dire tremblay donc ça c'est la
même chose et je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage c'est le même conclusion le truc
que je vais venir ici peut-être mettre
un petit bémol c'est que tu goûtes et
performant son instinct dragon 888 oui
d'abord comme aragon huit gènes one
c'est à dire on a des cars de quoi 20 25
% de performances entre les deux
générations mais on est quasiment
millions c'est pour ça je le remet en
perspective mais je trouve très cool il
est très bon en vidéo très bon en photo
et la tue vous faut si tourner beaucoup
jouent donc voila un petit peu un bon
retour sur ces deux smartphones je les
aime bien j'ai été très agréablement
surpris par le syndic cinq pros non pas
que je doutais qu'ils seraient pas bons
mais que je ne pensais pas qu'il irait
aussi loin et qu'on voit dans cet esprit
photographique sur un smartphone et
personnellement j'aime beaucoup donc
voilà big big up là dessus très chouette
smartphones a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous les trouvez s'il vous
intéresse vous m'aidez rien gagner
évidemment en bas la description pour
que je l'espère sinon j'aimais tout fait
je suis content vous aura représenté
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à les
tester et puis non écoutez ça montre
quoi ça montre la force de post montre
l'ingénierie de pot ça montre là où ils
vont en termes de photos de vidéos
répondre aux usages s'est pas encore
parfait je pense qu'on peut aller encore
plus loin bien évidemment mais sinon
tels qu'ils sont là ils me plaisent et
ça c'est cool voilà à vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez en banque au mental
s'est posé des questions suggestions
interrogations taper les dans les
commentaires et puis si vous n'êtes pas
abonné à les y passer moment sait jamais
la vidéo est très très longue désolé
pour cette longueur mais j'avais
tellement de choses à vous dire que je
vois je voulais pas qu'on coupe voulait
pas qu'on voit la confiance des trucs
comme ça gros focus auto vidéo il soit
plus un voile j'ai envie de vous en
parler pendant des heures faut que je
m'arrête faut que je me taise moment
mois d'août parce que je n'ai pas de
montre mais il faut que j'arrête il est
tard voilà je vous embrasse prenez soin
de vous il ya très vite qu'un
[Musique]